british prime minister boris johnson has
reversed plans
to ease coronavirus restrictions over
the christmas period
the turnaround he says is due to a new
strain of the virus which has seen a
surge in cases
he's imposed an effective lockdown on
london and south east england where the
new variant
is spreading more quickly in an
interview with british television the
health minister matt hancock said the
mutated virus could only be controlled
through social distancing
and suggested the tighter measures could
be in place for some time to come
shoppers in london made a final dash to
the stores before the new restrictions
went into force at midnight
under the latest rules many will be
forced to cancel their christmas plans
indoor meetings between different
households are now banned
as is all travel from areas under
stay-at-home orders
the number of cases are going up so i
guess it's needed it's not
it's not great for business it's not
good news for people but
uh i guess there's no way to avoid it
kind of upset about it
but what can we do
just have to hope for the best and
scope out the room
the decision to outlaw christmas
get-togethers in london and surrounding
areas
is a major climb down for british prime
minister boris johnson
we don't want to as i say to
to ban christmas to to cancel it
and i think that would be frankly
inhuman it is with a very heavy heart i
must tell you we cannot
continue with christmas as planned
johnson said a new viral strain had
forced him to change his mind
when the science changes we must change
our response when the virus changes
its method of attack we must change
our method of defense
and as your prime minister i sincerely
believe there is no alternative
open to me scientists say the evidence
shows the new variant of the coronavirus
is more infectious than other strains
it has been linked to a surge of
infections in recent weeks
in southeast england and now millions
of people living in the area will spend
christmas in lockdown
the seasonal sparkle dulled by the
pandemics force
well for more let's go straight to
london now on our correspondent
charlotte chelsea pill who's
standing by charlotte quite a sudden
turnaround
people in that report seemed resigned to
the news
what's the wider mood there in london
this morning
yeah rebecca well for so many people
here this is
heartbreaking news they had been told
that there would be a five-day period
where some of the covert restrictions
would be relaxed they'd be able to see
family indoors
that now has been ripped away from them
just days before christmas people are
having to rethink their plans just
behind me there's a
big queue of people at the local
butchers here having to quickly
stock up on emergency food no one a few
people were expecting that just days
before christmas these plans would have
to be changed
there were some people we did see images
of people getting on trains
out of london late last night before
these measures came into place the vast
majority though as we heard there
are resign to these restrictions and
understand why because
the concern about christmas slowly is
now
being matched about concern for what
this new variant of this virus
really means how it's going to impact us
in the months going forward
what it will mean not just for the
existing restrictions that are in place
but what could come in future to tackle
the fact it is thought to be more trans
transmissible
and that is something of course that
isn't just being watched closely here
the eyes of the world are on the uk in
this new variant to find out exactly
what it means and how it's spreading and
indeed
where it's spread yeah on christmas just
being the initial hurdle obviously this
has
bigger ramifications but it's thought
that this new strain has been spreading
since the beginning of the month now the
health minister has been talking today
did he say anything about why it's taken
the government so
long to respond
[Music]
well the health minister this morning
said information about this new variant
is still coming in now as we speak he
said
that they actually found out just how
transmissible it believed it could be
on friday he then said that they took
swift action on saturday
but of course for so many people who are
angry that the plans have been changed
they want to know why this wasn't
predicted in some form looking at the
case rises that have skyrocketed in
certain parts of the country
why people weren't warned earlier that
this five-day relaxation just
wasn't realistic so a lot of anger among
the public and opposition politicians
here as well
now obviously a lot of worry about this
new strain do we know anything more
about it how dangerous
it could be
yeah well we've had that transmission
could be as high as
uh 70 percent higher than the existing
variant that of course is an alarming
figure for
for a lot of people here there do have
to be some caveats
though from scientists mutations do
happen
it's not believed at this stage that
this variant is any more
deadly or more dangerous than the
existing variant and it is
believed currently that the vaccines and
treatments that have been uh
that are being rolled out across the uk
at the moment
uh will still be affected but this is of
course a a huge cause of concern
first minister nicholas sturgeon of
scotland saying that this is potentially
the most
dangerous structure since the beginning
of the pandemic
all right charlene tilson pill speaking
to us from london thank you
israel has begun its covert 19
vaccination campaign with healthcare
workers and people over the age of 60
at the front of the line prime minister
benjamin netanyahu already has had his
shot a successful vaccination program
could give him a much-needed
political boost the pandemic came when
his government was hit by a corruption
scandal
now it says it secured enough doses to
inoculate most of the population
but it's unclear whether the rollout
includes plans to vaccinate palestinians
living under israeli control
the streets of jericho aren't usually
this quiet
most businesses are shut apart from
pharmacies and bakeries
palestinian police are enforcing the
strict lockdown in the west bank
it's going to be like this till the
beginning of january
the palestinian-controlled parts of the
west bank were already suffering
economically before the pandemic
people are hoping they will get the job
soon
the palestinian people need a vaccine
which is certified by the world health
organization
it would help the palestinians who are
suffering a lot from the coronavirus
pandemic
which is adding to the problems of the
israeli occupation
with god's will this vaccine will be
effective
and we can escape this crisis which has
affected
every part of our life
at the coronavirus testing labs more and
more
samples are testing positive for covert
19.
countries in the region like saudi
arabia bahrain
and israel are beginning mass
vaccination programs
but the cash-strapped palestinian
government has not closed any supply
deals with drug companies yet
it will be many months before we receive
a quantity of the vaccine sufficient to
vaccinate people
on mass
bethlehem is usually bustling during the
christmas season
christians normally flock to the holy
sites on the west bank
but this year the celebrations will be
muted
as it struggles with the pandemic
lawmakers in the u.s have struck a late
night agreement on a multi-billion
dollar coronavirus relief package
clearing the way for the bill to be
voted on by both chambers before a
sunday deadline
the stimulus plan worth nearly a
trillion dollars has been
fought over for months and if passed it
would extend benefits for struggling
businesses and millions of
unemployed which are due to expire at
the end of the year
it's been a source of distress for many
families across the u.s
and a lady ramirez in california is no
different
she's balancing paying for rent and food
when out of a job
i got a food cart from school
that was one one way of bringing food to
the table
and then i
applied for help from a church a local
church
and they give these gift cards for
local supermarkets once every three
months
a lady lost her job as a waitress due to
covert 19
and she's been relying on savings food
gift cards and her nephew's part-time
job for extra cash
she's one of more than 12 million
americans who are unemployed
or without income who face losing their
benefits the day
after christmas when the aid package
passed by congress in the spring expires
unless lawmakers pass a new bill this
weekend
in new york marisol gonzalez relies on a
food bank
after losing her job as a massage
therapist
i have been coming to get food aid for
seven months because i lost my job to
the pandemic
and this helps me a lot estonia
food banks across the country are
struggling with the demand to continue
to support families like marisol's
who's managed to pay rent through a
series of small jobs
with a relief bill still not passed and
the pandemic still raging across the
country
it's unclear how long marisol and
millions like her
will struggle to make ends meet
the pandemic has battered tourism and
seaside resorts around the world
and the principality of monaco on the
french riviera riviera is no exception
but lately the tiny city-state has seen
a little boost
with a steady stream of day trippers
seeking a reprieve from tighter
restrictions
across the border in france
a sunny lunch time in monaco a few
minutes away in france
all the restaurants are closed because
of the pandemic and are set to stay that
way
till january the 20th at the earliest
here they are open
and heathing with people very many of
them french people
vietnamese
come to eat in a restaurant because in
france we're not allowed to
our parents give us orders you mustn't
leave the house
you mustn't go and eat there
but we are disobedient teenagers we
don't listen to our parents
so we cross the border to come and eat
out in monaco
it's an excellent thing it keeps the
economy going
do you think the french should do the
same thing
yes it would be a step towards getting
back to normal
economically
and it's not as if there aren't
anti-covert measures here in fact there
are quite a lot of them
ah the
the distance have to be one and a half
meters apart
no more than six people per table
[Music]
customers must come no later than 2 p.m
for lunch and 8 at night
when the curfew starts we give them a
permit
so they can go home later but everyone
has to be out
by 9 30.
monaco is an independent country that's
smaller than london's
hyde park everybody knows everybody
and people don't like to say anything
that might displease the princely family
that holds the economic as well as
political power
i eventually found one person who
thought monaco's covid policy was too
lax but he would only speak anonymously
i'm really against leaving the
restaurants open it's less about freedom
and thoughtlessness and showing off
freedom stops when other people's
freedom starts
when you trade on other people's liberty
you're not defending liberty anymore
on the contrary most though
as the holiday season gets underway
support the prince on this
as do many others with their feet or
rather their bellies
many french people celebrate new years
with a grand restaurant dinner
not this year not in france in any case
but many will be coming over the border
to monaco on the 31st
the restaurants here already outside
the riverbanks of the yangtze river in
china
in the chinese city of wuhan attract
visitors all year round
but in 2020 a lockdown and fears that
waterways could carry the coronavirus
kept people away without breaks now on
the wane
crowds are flocking back to the river
and some people are even taking a dip
warming up before a bracing daily ritual
in wuhan
these are the riverside regulars
refreshed by a frigid plunge
into the yangtze river many credit their
good health
to a vigorous swim through its murky
brown waters
there's a difference between swimming in
winter and swimming in summer
but as for winter swimming i can say
after you try
you may not be able to change the habit
and will be addicted to it
a famous figure from china's past
popularized the practice
chairman mao founder of communist china
in 1966 a stage swim in the yangtze
helped mao launch a political comeback
nearly 50 years on his strongman image
has remained
afloat among the river swimmers of wuhan
chairman mao was still swimming in the
yangtze in his 70s
so we learned from chairman mao to swim
in the big waves of the river right
having such a good source of water we
must learn from the practice we must
insist on swimming in the yangtze river
while a fun diversion for strong
swimmers the mighty yangtze
also poses a drowning hazard a volunteer
lifeguard squad
some 2000 strong make it their business
to be ready
so far they've chalked up 700 rescues
we swimmers saved people from the water
before we formed an official
volunteer squad but we did not have
scientific
rescue skills so we decided to get
organized
and train with each other to carry out
scientific rescue operations
as winter sets in a steady flow of
swimmers
slices through the water another sign of
the city coming back to life
and its people going out to seize the
day
here's a look now at some other
developments in the pandemic
the netherlands has responded to
britain's detection of a new covet
strain by banning
all flights arriving from the uk sydney
has banned dancing
singing and chanting indoors as it races
to contain a growing outbreak
bars and restaurants in australia's
biggest city also have to limit patron
numbers
israel has begun its vaccination
campaign with health care workers
and people over the age of 60 at the
front of the line it's unclear whether
the rollout includes plans to vaccinate
palestinians living under israeli
occupation